the irony of all of this by the way is
that as the libs are pretending that I
called for mass murder
a very prominent liberal went on
national television and literally called
for murder
we have experienced many decades now of
having agency over our body of being
able to determine when and how many
children to have we know what that feels
like we know what that's done for our
lives we're not going back I don't care
what the laws are we're not doing that
I think the women will rise up that's
the activists that's Jane speaking and
and she probably will get a Nobel Prize
it is the truth I'm not going to do it
besides marching and protesting what
else do you suggest
ions
overnight it's not a miraculous what did
you say Murder She
said she's just I don't say that or you
don't know they'll pick up on that yeah
she's just kidding it's well let me talk
to you about it
let's move on and talk about Jane's
activism which is legendary
oh she's just kidding she's just kidding
you look at Jane Fonda Jane Fonda is not
kidding at all there's not even the hint
of a theatrical kind of smile or wink
here she is dead serious which tells you
a lot about the left tells you two
things in particular one when they whine
and cry and clutch their pearls and
completely rewrite your words to make it
sound as though you're advocating
violence when you've never done any such
thing it's completely disingenuous
and it's completely disingenuous because
of the second point which is that
the libs would happily Advocate
political violence against their their
enemies
the libs the libs have made this point
all week with my transgenderism comments
they said you can't distinguish between
an idea and the people who Express that
idea there's no distinction to be made
if you criticize a bad idea then you are
calling for the death of the people who
hold that idea which is which is absurd
anybody with even a slightly developed
rational faculty is able to distinguish
between bad ideas and people who believe
bad ideas
but the libs don't fall into that group
the libs truly make no distinction
between those things and so when the
libs are calling for the eradication of
an idea
they actually are in in certainly in the
case of Jane Fonda here calling for the
eradication of people it's sometimes
said that every accusation from the libs
is a confession and Jane Fonda just just
confessed something confessed that this
whole past week of the libs rewriting my
words is because they themselves
make no such distinction between ideas
and people a few months early here but
I'm
I'm prepared to bring this out now
Gotta Give a hat tip to jack besobic for
calling my attention to this
June 21st 2018
Greta tunberg Saint Greta of the Blessed
sailboat tweets out
a top climate scientist is warning that
climate change will wipe out all of
humanity unless we stop using fossil
fuels over the next five years
Greta has apparently deleted the tweet
I'm just going to look at my
calculations here it's in 2018 now it's
2023 carry the seven oh
it's been five years Alma it's been four
years and what nine months
we are approaching the end of the world
aren't we and yet
the behavior of people might seem to
predict the end of the world but the
natural facts of the earth seem just
fine
another Doomsday Prophecy
has not come true
as all the rest of the Doomsday
prophecies have not come true this is
what the libs always do
they tell you that in 12 years 10 years
five years the world is going to end
unless you do exactly what they demand
that you do unless you give them all the
money and all the power and then then
maybe we'll avert the end of the world
and then those prophecies never come
true but they're so far into the future
that the libs assume that you'll never
call them out when they don't come true
this has been the case since
well since all of human history but it
goes back to the the population Bond
Paul Ehrlich and the population bomb
said in 1970 that within 10 years there
would be Mass famines the world
population would plummet it was
inevitable we could start now
sterilizing people and and killing
babies through abortion and we might
need to even coerce it but it's still
not going to help all that much these
these predictions led directly to
policies in places like India which
sterilized lots of poor people in
exchange for the use of utilities places
like China which had the one one child
policy killed Untold numbers of babies
because of these sorts of predictions
and then
didn't come true
didn't matter actually
50 years on the world population doubled
malnutrition was in an all-time low
oops got it wrong it's always wrong it's
all these predictions
about climate change about the
population bomb about from the end of
the world they're always false and it's
important
to celebrate when they don't come true
shouldn't we be happy shouldn't Greta be
happy why doesn't Greta retweet this and
say hello how wonder I don't really know
how the swedes sound don't you know this
is so wonderful the world hasn't ended
yippee hooray no they're upset when it
doesn't happen they hide it they have to
delete it
remember oh my calculations were a
little wrong uh but uh three more years
if you don't give me what I want it's
three more years that's when the world
is going to end okay see you in three
more years
what's the point of all this the energy
Sector 8 for Joe Biden explained what
the point of all of this is
I think China has done
um has been very sensitive and has
actually invested a lot in their
Solutions uh to achieve their goals so
we're hopeful that you know we can all
learn from what China is doing but the
amount of money that they're investing
in clean energy is actually you know
encouraging
there it is here's the point
the point is to make our system of
government look more like China's
it's not just Jennifer granholm and the
Biden Administration is saying this the
world economic Forum has been saying
this liberal Elites all over the world
have been saying this they look at
China's model and they say oh that's a
pretty good way for the elite to take a
lot of power over the people
what's the model the model is mass
surveillance the model is a social
credit system and the model is
the total control of people's habits of
living all the way down to what kind of
stoves they use to heat their pots of
gruel all the way down to what kind of
Transportation they're allowed to take
whether or not they're able to leave
their homes
all the way down and how do they justify
it
they justified in the name of this
eschatology of climate change this woke
pseudo-religion that has all of the
elements of a religion all over the kind
of
quasi sacraments
all of the kinds of rituals all the
kinds of liturgical garments and of
course
the end times prophecies
that climate change exists to animate
this move away from our traditional way
of life toward this new way of life and
it's not just that this new way of life
is communist it's not just that China is
a purely communist country it's not
China uses Market mechanisms
China I don't think Xi Jinping is the
most ideologically Orthodox Marxist
that's ever lived
and frankly I don't think that their
system is all that different from the
system in the west we have the same kind
of mass surveillance that China does in
fact we have a much more sophisticated
system of mass surveillance that we use
against our own people
we have a social credit system whether
the United States wants to admit it or
not
if you if you contradict the ruling
regime you can have your
Uber shutdown you can be put on a no-fly
list you can be debanked this has
happened to political dissidents in the
United States
and because our society is increasingly
moving away from cash you can be you can
be frozen out of the the system out of
the financial system
you won't be able to protest either
because you'll be de-platformed from
social media which is the Public Square
doesn't look all that different so when
when the ruling class liberals tell you
we want to look like China
believe them they're telling you their
plans
and and you're you're even seeing this
impulse in the way they use language
the idea that in the total state in a
totalitarian regime
everything down to your private thoughts
is controlled by the ruling power
the words that you are allowed to use
history
what actually happened what people
actually said no no you didn't hear that
no no no you didn't see that no no no
history is always changing
reality is always changing the party
whatever the party says is always right
it's music Monday baby
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it become a member
right now if you're not already a member
the earlywire.com Knowles use code
Knowles at checkout for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign